Доброго дня, дорогі школярі!
Сподіваємось, що вам буде цікаво дізнатися
щось про Антарктиду взагалі
і про українців в Антарктиді зокрема
Для початку давайте згадаємо, що спадає
на думку першим при словах
Арктика та Антарктика
Це – холод
Дійсно, це два найхолодніші регіони нашої планети
Але вони дуже різні
На жаль, оскільки вони обидва далекі і холодні,
в головах абсолютної більшості людей
Мабуть, майже у всіх, крім тих, хто там працює,
вони змішуються в якусь
одну велику таку білу масу,
де просто крига, сніг і де
разом гріються білі ведмеді і пінгвіни
Насправді це зовсім не так
Два полярні регіони нашої планети в чомусь схожі, а в чомусь дуже різні
Давайте для початку пригадаємо, де що
Якщо ми стоїмо обличчям до карти або до глобуса,
то Арктика в нас буде зверху, а Антарктика знизу
Це перша відмінність
Друга відмінність – це пори року
В Арктиці такі самі пори року, як у нас
Тобто, коли у нас літо, так само
літо і на Північному полюсі
На Південному полюсі все у протифазі:
коли літо у нас – там зима і навпаки
І, звичайно, є більш суттєві відмінності
В Антарктиді в нас посередині
велика-велика маса землі
Суцільний континент покритий кригою,
а довкола неї холодний Південний океан
В Арктиці все прямо навпаки
Там ніби кільцем сходяться
Північна Америка та Євразія
Сходяться берегами
Між ними якраз посередині
така водна порожнеча, покрита кригою
Північний Льодовитий океан
Арктика це насамперед плавуча крига на воді
Антарктика це насамперед величезний
кількакілометровий завдовжки
континентальний материк,
а довкола нього, навпаки,
відносно чиста і відносно вільна вода
Так само в Арктиці і в Антарктиці
живуть дуже різні живі істоти
Тут є декілька, можна сказати,
хрестомаційних культових істот,
які асоціюються з полярними регіонами
Але вони ніколи не бачаться одне з одним
Якщо ми говоримо про Арктику, то це насамперед
символом можна назвати білого ведмедя
Також північного оленя і моржа
Так ось всі ці три істоти ніколи не бували
в Антарктиді і не будуть
Вони живуть тільки в Арктиці
Натомість навпаки – в Арктиці
ніколи не побувають пінгвіни
Вони живуть виключно у Південній півкулі, виключно в Антарктиді
Так само виключно в Антарктиді
живуть морські леопарди
І ще цілий ряд інших тюленів
Хоча у цих тюленів
вже є північний родич – арктична нерпа
І там, і там водяться кити,
але, знову ж таки, кити різні
В Арктиці плавають однорогі кити
нарвали і кити білуги
Тоді як в Антарктиці насамперед плавають,
горбаті кити і кити мінке
Спільного є хіба що косатка
Так званий «кит-убивця».
Косатка – найбільший хижак
і в Північних, і в Південних океанах
От він трапляється в Арктиці і в Антарктиці
Всі решта там один одного
ніколи побачити не можуть
Коли мене запитують:
«От яка вона, ота Антарктида?»
Чесно кажучи, це завжди викликає спершу посмішку, бо, насамперед, вона велика!
І тому не може бути однаковою всюди
Насправді зона дії договору про Антарктику,
тобто Антарктичний континент
і Південний океан довкола нього
Це 10% площі нашої планети. Уявляєте?
Насправді це неочевидно, коли
здалеку дивишся на глобус,
а насправді 10% площі планети це чимало
І, звичайно, там не може
бути однакових умов усюди
Насамперед дуже сильно відрізняється центральна частина Антарктиди і приморські регіони
Центральна Антарктида це,
можна сказати, інша планета
Там крижаний панцир, завдовжки понад 2 кілометри, покриває весь континент
На поверхні цього крижаного панцира
розріджене повітря
Дуже-дуже холодно
Що значить дуже холодно?
Це влітку -30, а взимку до -80
Зафіксовані навіть ще трішки нижчі температури
Щоб ви розуміли, взимку туди
навіть не літають літаки
Тому що при температурах нижче -50
Якщо літак зупинить свої двигуни,
він далі вже повторно не заведе
Оце, можна сказати, найбільш наближення
на нашій планеті умови до Марсу
Дещо інша картина на берегах океану
Там значно тепліше, порівняно
з центральною частиною
І тут сильно відрізняються
Східна та Західна Антарктида
От ми у Західній Антарктиді
Загалом у тому регіоні, який називається
Морська Антарктика
Ці слова одразу говорять дуже багато
З одного боку, в нас значно тепліше
В нас взимку буває там -30, -35
А влітку взагалі температури
переважно бігають довкола нуля
-5, +5, -5, +5
Якщо в Центральній і Східній Антарктиді дуже сухо, от дійсно майже так сухо як на Марсі
І ті шматки скель, які там непокриті кригою,
вони виглядають саме як пустеля
Там не росте взагалі ніщо
То у нашій частині Антарктиди
навпаки – дуже-дуже волого
В Морській Антарктиці постійно йде
випаровування води з поверхні океану
І тому в нас вологість порядку 100%
270 днів на рік ідуть які-небудь опади.
Або сніг, або мокрий сніг
Або сніг з дощем в найтепліші дні
Ну і, звичайно, вітри
В Центральній Антарктиді вітри дмуть
практично завжди в одному напрямку
Від полюса вони ніби отак скочуються
по крижаному панциру в бік до океанів
Це ідеальні умови для того, щоб там
встановлювати вітрові електростанції
В нас картина інша. В нас вітер змінюється
від повного штилю до штормового
І швидкість вітру в 20 м/сек – це у нас
доволі стандартна швидкість
Він часто в нас такий
А от, якщо уже по-справжньому поривчастий,
то це 40 м/сек
Антарктида далеко не завжди була
такою білосніжною, крижаною
і майже непридатною для життя,
як ми зараз її бачимо
Мільйони років тому там були тропічні ліси
Мешкало дуже багато різних живих істот
Включно із динозаврами,
включно із давніми птахами, ссавцями, рептиліями
Однак, як ви пригадуєте
із шкільних уроків географії,
континенти, на яких ми з вами живемо,
не стоять на місці
Ми з вами живемо фактично на плавучих острівцях
Так, ці острівці великі, цілі континенти
І пливуть вони дуже-дуже повільно
із швидкістю в пару сантиментрів на рік
Однак за мільйони років вони доволі
суттєво відпливають один від одного
Це ви в школі вчили
Історія сучасної Антарктиди це також історія того
як вона поволі-поволі відпливала
від Південної Америки та Австралії
все далі на південь, поки нарешті зайняла оте положення, яке нам з вами знайоме, тобто полярне
По мірі того як Антарктида дрейфувала на південь, потроху вона ставала все холоднішою
Однак остаточно її доля визначилась
приблизно 20 мільйонів років тому
Антарктида відокремилась від всього світу широким таким кільцем дуже холодної води,
яка по годинниковій стрілці поволі
обходить Антарктичний континент
і дуже різко відрізає його від усієї решти світу
Це визначило долю континенту,
який потроху став вихолоджуватися
Від полюсу почала розростатись полярна шапка,
а з другого боку вже чекав
абсолютно холодний Південний океан
Останні 10 років Міжнародна океанографічна комісія визнає Південний океан окремим океаном
нарівні з Тихим, Атлантичним, Індійським
та Північним льодовитим
Хоча у цього океану лише один берег,
в нього є тільки південний берег
Це берегова лінія Антарктиди
А на півночі він ніби зливається
з Атлантичним, Індійським і Тихим
Формально межу нібито й не проведеш,
але насправді вона є і вона дуже відчутна
Це так звана циркумполярна течія
І ця водна маса насправді достатньо сильно відмінна від сусідніх водних мас інших трьох океанів
І майже з ними не змішується,
тому що ніби отак краєм тільки «треться»
Ви знаєте, це навіть видно, коли вживу
ти йдеш на кораблі в Антарктиду
Ідеш по океану і бачиш один колір води,
Далі ти на якийсь момент потрапляєш у таку потужну смугу туманів,
де взагалі ніс корабля важко побачити
А потім, коли ти виходиш із цього туману, ти вже бачиш воду абсолютно іншого кольору
Значно прозорішу, значно холоднішу
Це означає, що ти потрапив із Атлантичного
або Тихого океану до океану Південного
А ота смуга, коли ти проходив кілька годин
чи навіть пару днів, у тумані
оце і є власне оця вузька лінія,
де океани межують між собою
Оскільки «стикаються» водні маси дуже різної температури, то частина води випаровується
Отже, Південний океан став дуже надійний бар'єром, який відокремив Антарктиду від усього іншого світу
А про те, хто із тварин все ж таки спромігся подолати таку перешкоду
як холодний Південний океан
і заселити Антарктиду – про це наступного разу